Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain the American post-apocalyptic
action-adventure film called “Oblivion.”
Spoilers ahead! Watch out and take care!
The premise of the movie is set in the year 2077.
An alien species called the scavengers plan to
attack the earth for its resources. They first
destroy the moon causing a series of tsunamis
and earthquakes on earth. As the humans recover
from the natural calamities, the scavengers
attack them and a war breaks out between the
two species. At last, humans eventually win the
war using nuclear weapons. But as an aftermath,
the earth is no longer habitable as most
of it turns into a radioactive wasteland.
To survive, the humans evacuate to one of Saturn's
moons called Titan. This evacuation is managed by
officials who inhabit a large spaceship in orbit
around Earth called the Tet. Tet has also set up
the hydro rig generators on the earth. These
are used to generate seawater and convert it
into fusion energy for the humans in Titan.
The last two people left on the earth are a
couple. The husband, Jack Harper, and the
wife Vika live in a tower high above the
clouds. They both work for the Tet and manage
the hydro rig generators. Jack serves as Tech 49
whose job also involves repairing the drones,
the device designed to detect and terminate
remaining Scavengers on Earth. Vika mostly
stays inside the Tower to keep an eye on him,
as his co-ordinator. At the beginning of the
movie, Jack wakes up to a dream of an unknown
woman. He has been having recurring dreams for a
long time. Jack narrates that he doesn’t remember
anything that happened before the war as their
memories were erased for the mission’s secrecy.
The couple’s mission on earth will be over in
two weeks, after which, they will join the others
on Titan, leaving the earth with no humans.
They continue their normal morning routine after
which, Jack leaves for the regular inspection
of the scavenger killing drones. He sees that
two of them have been damaged by the scavengers
overnight. Meanwhile, Vika contacts the mission
director from Tet named Sally. She is reported of
everything going on earth by Vika. Jack reaches
the broken drone and lands to repair it while Vika
helps him by monitoring the areas for scavengers.
Jack successfully repairs the drone even though he
is short of available equipment. The drone quickly
flies away after scanning Jack and finding out he
is not a threat. Jack then searches for the second
drone but is disappointed when Vika tells him that
they have lost the beacon. Without the beacon,
they have a hard time finding the drone but an
ambitious Jack gets on his bike to look for it.
He drives through the plane lands that once used
to be the oceans and reaches a sinkhole. Jack
locates the second drone inside it but Vika asks
him to leave because it is too dangerous. However,
Jack ignores her and ties a rope to his bike to
go down the hole. Seeing this, Vika requests the
mission control to send a backup to his location.
When Jack reaches the bottom, he sees the remains
of an old building. He somehow gets to the
drone but soon realizes that it is a trap
set by the scavengers. They drag him by his leg
but Jack uses his weapon and fights back. At last,
he is almost killed but the backup
drone arrives at the right time.
It kills all the scavengers and saves Jack. After
everything settles down, Jack returns home.
Jack has been growing a flowery weed which he
hands to Vika as a gift. To his disappointment,
she throws it away saying
that it might contain toxins.
At dinner, Jack reveals that the scavengers were
trying to capture him today. He is confused as to
why they wouldn’t want to kill him. Vika, however,
dismisses the conversation and seductively invites
him to the swimming pool. Jack joins her a
while later and the night ends as they kiss.
The next morning, they wake up to the noise of a
loud explosion. Jack quickly gets on his jet and
makes his way to the area where the explosion took
place. Sally calls Vika and tells her that one of
the hydro rigs has had a meltdown and has been
destroyed permanently. On his way to the scene,
Jack receives a strange radio signal from an
unknown source. It makes him curious, so he
makes his way to the source of the said signal. He
reaches the remains of the empire state building
which he often visits in his recurring dream.
Jack cuts a wire and gets rid of the signal,
thinking it is of use to the scavengers.
Then, he does a parameter check and almost
crosses the border to the radiation zone where
they aren’t allowed to go. Before returning home,
he goes to a house in the middle of the woods
that he had found on one of his expeditions.
He comes here whenever he feels down and has
made the house his own with decorations. Jack
eventually falls asleep and dreams of an unknown
girl in the empire state building. A while later,
he wakes up to see some sort of vessel
falling from the sky and quickly gets
in his jet. At the same time, Vika contacts him
to inform him about the location of the vessel.
Vika also contacts Sally who tells them to ignore
the vessel because they have already gone through
a lot of trouble for the day. Following the
order, Vika asks Jack to return home but he
dismisses her and lands on the crash site.
There, he notices that the capsule is a pre-war
device. A confused Jack finds hibernation pods
with humans inside them. He is more surprised to
see that one woman inside the pod is the girl
he always sees in his dreams. Before he can
contemplate what is going on, a drone arrives
there and starts shooting the hibernation pod,
scanning them as scavengers. It destroys every
pod but Jack stops it from killing the girl.
As he transfers the girl to take her
home, some scavengers from nearby
watch him. Back at the tower, Vika is surprised
to see Jack with the hibernation pod. They
quickly get the girl out of the pod and she calls
Jack’s name before passing out. Sometime later,
she gains consciousness and introduces herself
as Julie. Other than that, she doesn’t tell them
anything about her mission or her crew.
While the three eat, Jack tells Julie about
the war that caused the humans to evacuate the
earth. He says that Julie must have been in that
pod for over sixty years but the girl just
laughs at the thought. Later at night, Vika
tells Jack that she wants Julie gone. She wants
to report her existence to the mission control
and make them take her to Titan as well. However,
Jack retaliates saying that the drones sent by
mission control tried to kill her so asking
them for help would be foolish. As they talk,
a scavenger from below the tower keeps an eye on
them. Then, we see Julie looking at the horizon
through a window. She asks Jack to take her
to her ship to retrieve the flight recorder.
She feels like she is in a dream and has to
know what happened to her crew before the crash.
Jack hesitates, declaring that the scavengers
are on a run at night but Julie insists.
At last, they fly to the site of the crash
again. A distressed Vika waits for them at home,
unsettled by her husband getting close to another
woman. The other two reach the site and get the
recorder. But before they can return, they are
attacked and knocked out by the scavengers.
Vika sees this from the cameras and freaks
out. The following morning, she gets a call
from Sally who asks her for reports. Vika doesn’t
tell her about Julie and makes up an excuse for
Jack being absent. Meanwhile, Jack and Julie are
tied up and taken to the scavengers' hideout.
To Jack’s surprise, a human being sits in front of
him. The man introduces himself as Malcolm Beech
and seems to recognize Jack. He asks Jack if he
remembers the things from his past but Jack says
his memories were removed for his own good. Then,
Beech questions him if he has seen a scavenger
up close. Just then, the lights turn on and
several humans standing on platforms are seen.
Jack is surprised because he believed he
and Vika were the only ones left on earth.
Beech finally tells Jack that the scavengers they
have been killing are actually humans and the
mission control has been lying to him. The thought
is unbelievable to Jack and he declares it to be
a lie. Then, they take Jack to show him around
the hideout and tell him about their mission.
They want to destroy the Tet which is sucking
out the earth’s resources. For this purpose,
they have brought down Julia’s ship odyssey
earlier. The ship had explosives that had the
power to blow up the Tet. Now, they have the
explosives and they have a drone to plant the
explosive but the only one who can program the
drone is Jack. Hence, they need his help. Jack,
however, retaliates saying that the Tet has
human beings up there who he cannot kill.
An enraged Sargent threatens to kill
Julia if Jack doesn’t oblige. Right then,
a drone arrives at the entrance of the hideout
and scans it for scavengers. Beech takes Jack
out of the second entrance and asks him to go
to the “radiation zone” to find the answers.
Jack and Vika have always been told to stay out of
the radiation zone, so he doesn’t know what is on
the other side. At last Beech lets Jack and Julia
go and they fly to the empire state building.
There, Jack tells her about his dreams, and to
his surprise, Julia reveals she is his wife.
Before everything went down, they were sent on
a mission on a research flight to Titan. The
crew consisted of five people in hibernation pods
while Vika and Jack were piloting the spaceship.
But before they reached Titan, they discovered
an alien object in space. That alien object was
Tet. Julia has no memory of what happened
after but Jack begins to remember the time
he and Julia were in love. They get closer to
kiss but are interrupted by Jack’s jet which has
come to pick them up. Vika sees the two getting
close through the cameras and is heartbroken.
When Jack and Julia return to the tower, Vika
doesn’t let them in. She reports the mission
control about Julia and tells them Jack
is unfit for service. To their surprise,
the mission control assigns a drone to kill both
of them because they are of no use anymore. The
drone kills Vika but Jack is saved at the last
minute. He and Julia run away from the tower
only to be followed by the drones. They get into
an intense battle in the sky and their jet crash
lands on the radiation zone. Jack composes
himself and sees a jet flying overhead. To
his utter surprise, another Jack comes out of
the jet. Both of them are completely in shock
to see each other. The only difference between
the two is that Jack’s code number is Tech 49
and the doppelganger’s is Tech 52. They get
into a fight and 49 quickly overpowers 52 but
Julia is shot in the process.
Jack thinks of ways to save her and
gets on Tech 52’s jet. He then flies
to Tech 52’s tower and meets his wife
Vika. He acquires a healing device from the tower
and comes back to Julia to save her. Jack cannot
comprehend that behind the radiation zone is
his doppelganger living the same life as him.
He and Julia then drive to the lake house
that Jack always visits. The following day,
they return to the scavenger's hideout and meet
Beech again. Beech finally reveals that Tet is
actually an intelligent alien device that
goes around the galaxy to steal resources
from planets. It had its eyes on the earth for
a long time. The ship that Julia and Jack were
in was attacked by Tet but Jack managed to
detach the capsule with the hibernation pods
before he and Vika were captured.
After that, Tet made several versions
of Jack and Vika and sent them down to take
over humanity. Their memories were wiped so
they wouldn’t question the mission but Beech
saw Jack save Julie and understood that he
was different. He finally welcomes Jack back to
the human’s side. Now, Jack repairs the drone
that is supposed to take the explosive to Tet
and destroy it. But before they can launch it,
they are attacked by three other drones. A fight
ensues between Beech’s group and the drones in
which most of their crew is killed. At last, Beech
is gravely hurt and the drone they were supposed
to launch is also destroyed. Now, Jack takes the
responsibility to get the explosive to the Tet.
Julie insists on joining him, so he puts her in a
hibernation pod, and the two take off for Tet.
On his way, Jack listens to the flight recording
that was retrieved from Julie’s ship. While
listening to it, he remembers what happened on the
ship before they were captured. In the present,
Jack finally reaches the Tet, and the doors open
for him to enter. Inside, he sees thousands of
Jacks being created in incubation pods. He finally
comes before the Tet which is a triangular device.
Jack then opens the hibernation pot in front
of it only to reveal it has Beech inside of
it. He had left Julie safe in the lake house
and brought Beech with him so the Tet wouldn’t
suspect his intentions. He finally sets off
the explosion and destroys the alien device,
saving humanity and earth’s resources. However,
both Jack and Beech die in the explosion.
Cut to three years later. Julia has given
birth to Jack’s daughter and the two still live
in the lake house. One day, they are
approached by Beech’s surviving crew.
The crew has also brought Jack, Tech 52 with it.
The movie ends as he meets eyes with Julia.
Subscribe for more videos like
this, turn on the notification,
and leave a like to help the channel out.
Thanks for watching.